hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast refinement of epigenetic
approaches in neuroscience presented by
dr. richard lee i'm susie valdez of
laborat and i will be your moderator for
today's event
we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider a
virtual event and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
today's event is sponsored by ad uhland
technologies Agilent Technologies Inc is
a global leader in life sciences
diagnostics and applied chemical market
it's a premier laboratory partner for a
better world
Agilent works with customers in more
than a hundred countries providing
instruments software services and
consumables for the entire laboratory
workflow before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and at any time
you want during the presentation just
click on the green Q&A button located in
the lower left of your presentation
window and type your questions into the
box that appears on the screen we'll
answer as many questions as we can as
far as you can at the end of the
presentation also please notice that we
will be viewing the presentation in this
slide window to a larger window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button to let us know
that you are having a problem this is an
educational webinar and thus offers
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on a CD
button located on the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process for obtaining your credit I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker Richard Lee PhD assistant
professor from John Hopkins University
School of Medicine
Richard Lee is a John Hopkins University
lifer he received his BS and biomedical
engineering and a PhD in molecular
biology and genetics at the John Hopkins
University currently he is an assistant
professor in the department of
psychiatry and Ismene
research interest is elucidating the
epigenetic mechanisms of the HPA axis
and the neuro and doctrine of hormones
in the context of psychiatric disorders
the employs books
candidate loci and genome-wide
approaches to identify neuronal of genes
and pathways that are epigenetically
affected by stress and glucocorticoids
he is designed and implemented both
microarray and sequencing based
platforms for genome-wide DNA
methylation projects and claim the charm
platform and the sure select methyl seek
target enrichment system for the rat
genome please join me in welcoming dr.
Richard Lee I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you for
the wonderful introduction so as
mentioned I will talk to you today a
little bit about epigenetic approaches
in neuroscience it's a bit of a work in
progress because you know AI training is
originally in epigenetics and as I
started to dive I guess into the realm
of psychiatry and neuroscience I
realized that the methods that I
normally use were somewhat inappropriate
or inadequate so I had to kind of pick
up things along the way different tools
and techniques to be able to effectively
examine epigenetic modifications in the
brain so today I would just give you up
in the beginning of your brief I guess a
crash course background on might be
genetics and then tell you a little bit
about some of the tools that we use and
then because I'm not just describing
techniques and platforms I'm going to
tell you a little bit of my research
background and how it evolved over the
past couple years and necessitated for
me to think a little bit about
neuroscience and how I could merge the
field of neuroscience and epigenetics to
answer some of the questions and then I
will give you
justification for a genome-wide platform
called methyl seek for looking at DNA
methylation and then going to detail
about the agilent you're select Mouse
methyl seek platform and how I've used
it to answer some questions that I have
about Google coracoid signaling and
epigenetics and then as I think a little
bit more about discoveries in in the
neuroscience and in the brain how I had
to pick up some neuroscience techniques
along the way to answer some of those
questions in a more appropriate context
so briefly what is epigenetics be the
textbook definition is of course the
study of variable changes in gene
function or phenotypes caused by
mechanisms other than changes in DNA
sequence
it's basically a study of measurement
study a measurement of transcriptional
context or potential and inertia so it's
the architecture within the nucleus that
you would kind of examine to see whether
a particular gene is able to transcribe
or make mRNA or it becomes silenced so
there are three kind of flavors of
epigenetic changes epigenetic
modifications one that I will primarily
about today is DNA methylation the other
one being histone modification and the
third one which is fairly hot topic now
these days is the non-coding RNA such as
you know micro RNA then link RNA you
know long non-coding RNAs so to tell you
briefly about DNA methylation
it's a ch3 modification that gets
covalently attached to the base pair
cytosine and not in all cases but
generally you can think of it as
methylation being associated with gene
silencing so on the DNA itself on the on
the base pairs of DNA especially at the
cpg dinucleotides
the sea or the cytosine becomes methyl
and what that what happens with that is
that it's it confers binding activity to
specific protein such as you know MEC b2
that binds methylated CPG and then
silences transcription on the other hand
if it's unmethylated it's thought to
just promote transcription because there
is nothing that is hindering
transcription factors from binding and I
will talk a little bit about the
interaction between methylation and
histone modifications in the next couple
of slides and of course we have the
histone modifications these are proteins
in a Optim octamer format that the DNA
is wrapped around and there are multiple
modifications such as a saturation
phosphorylation and even methylation on
different histone residues that either
that promote either gene transcription
gene activation or silencing so this is
involved in you chromatin ization or
heterochromatinization of evolved
histones and this is another slide just
demonstrating how complex the histone
modifications are and this is one of the
reasons why I tend to shy away from
working on histones I do have some
experience working with histones I
quickly realize it's just quite
complicated to think of which
modifications lead to what and what
proteins bind these different
modifications and then of course you
know you have you know not only the
histone modifications in its variety but
different enzymes that as I mentioned
that modified histones in this case we
have for example a h stacks that are
histone deacetylase inhibitors that
remove acetyl groups from specific
lysine residues on histones and so it
promotes heterochromatinization of your
histones and then oppositely there's the
the other you know histone
acetyltransferases such as p300 that
provides or attaches SL groups to these
light seems to promote gene
transcription and then of course we have
the on translated RNAs that are not made
into proteins but they perform very
important functions in terms of gene
regulation so in a a sequence specific
way they bind their for example mrna
target and they affect transcription
translation of specific genes and as you
may already know there's plenty of a
role that epigenetics plays in biology
and disease well the prime example of
that being X inactivation we know that
females have two X chromosomes one of
which is inactivated so when the one of
the chromosomes are inactivated it
actually uses all three mechanisms of
epigenetics to achieve that purpose and
then we have cell differentiation it's
especially when you think of stem cells
you know any cells in your body they
have the same DNA sequence yet they
perform very different functions and
part of that is being mediated by
epigenetic differences and then of
course you have cancer obviously there
are you know mutations genetic mutations
that occur in cancer but there's a lot
of epigenetic mechanisms as well since
you know turning a normal tissue into
tumors requires cellular reprogramming
through epigenetic modifications and of
course there's genomic imprinting which
basically based on whether you get your
chromosome from your mother or your
father there is a differential gene
expression so going back to X
inactivation it's a very good example of
epigenetics because the inactive
excrement
own actually employs all three
mechanisms so you have HP one which is
the heterochromatin protein one binding
to you one side of the chromosome and
then the other side is covered by exist
RNA which is the acting activation in
silencing transcript which is a long
non-coding RNA that coats the inactive X
chromosome and then when you look at the
figure on the bottom you can see that
largely the inactive chromosome the X
chromosome has lots of methylation
content so if you look at the gene PG k1
which is on the X chromosome in males
versus females you'll see that for males
that need that one x chromosome copy
most of the genes are unmethylated
whereas in females the methylation is
anywhere from forty to fifty percent to
indicate that and this one of the two x
chromosomes are methylated and this is
genomic imprinting this is the classic
imprinted locus 11p 15.5 you have Vig f2
and h19 genes and the pink color
basically shows pink boxes shows both
show the genes that are transcribed off
of the maternal chromosome whereas the
blue boxes show genes that are currently
transcribed and so this is a perfect
case where epigenetics plays a role and
the mechanism that is has been
established as we demonstrated is that
the differential methylation of regions
that are called DMR's or differentially
methylated regions confer binding to
insulator proteins which is CPCs and
nucleophile teaming that block the
access of enhancers to specific genes in
this case if it's methylated at the
bottom panel there is no binding theory
and insulator protein so the e
representing an enhancer could activate
the IGF 2 locus whereas in the maternal
chromosome there is an insulator protein
and it inhibits prevents access of the
enhancer
to the IGF to Lopez so that it kind of
activates the culture h19 gene so you
get this reciprocal expression pattern
when you have genomic imprinting and
then of course of course through
epigenetic mechanisms so the tools of
epigenetics I will briefly mention
several of these of course as detection
of DNA methylation histone modifications
these are as I will go into detail on
some of the examples the kind of Brennan
murder of epigenetics and then we could
do either candidate gene approaches or a
genome-wide this is now it has become
much more I guess comprehensive due to
the sequencing platforms that are out
there and then one of the tools that I
will go into greater detail is a is the
fluorescence activated cell sorting so
this is not detecting epigenetic
modification per se but I think that
it's a very important tool for you to be
able to enrich for specific populations
of cells and this becomes highly
relevant when I talk about approaches in
neuroscience towards the end of this
talk so I will talk primarily on about a
DNA methylation because that's that is a
bulk of my research and how we detect a
DNA methylation there's quite a few
tools you could use methylation
sensitive enzymes but I choose myself
like conversion of DNA because it I
think it is the most it provides the
best base pair resolution in terms of
detecting methylation changes so what
happens doing by supply conversion of
DNA is that the cytosine becomes
sulphonated this is you buy a nice
little kit from you know heisting or
enzyme or research to convert your
genomic DNA and
so if it if the cytosine in the context
of cpg dinucleotides is methylated it is
prevented from becoming sulphonated
whereas if it is unmethylated it becomes
salt elated and doing a hydrolytic
deamination step with default formation
the unmethylated cytosines becomes your
so and so in the subsequent PCR
procedures it becomes a key whereas if
the cytosine is methylated it survives
the kind of d by stop by conversion step
and it remains of C so what happens at
the end is you have a bisulfite
converted of sequence where all the C's
that are not in the CPG context have
been converted away to T's and then you
have C's only remaining in the CPG
context where the C has been was
methylated previously so when you
compare your final sequence to the
original sequence you could tell whether
a piece of DNA has was methylated before
the bisulfite conversion and this is a
kind of a very simple schematic of how
we determine percent methylation
previously what we did was we my
software e to the DNA did PCR
amplification and then we you know to
get it to the core or if you have a a
Bri 3100 sequencer you did Sanger
sequencing so then what you what you did
is to have primers on either side go see
points over the CPGs and determine
whether there's there are you know what
the cg composition is at that particular
nucleus but dinucleotide and then what
you wanted to do if you want to be a
little more specific is to clone it into
a vector using topo cloning kit and then
take a bacterial colony that represents
one type of species of DNA and then when
you did Sanger sequencing on that
particular plasmid with that DNA
sequence you can either get a seed or a
key to indicate methylation status so
then for a particular experiment whether
to determine whether a CPG is methylated
or not you will pick like 20 colonies
and look at the ratio of C G's versus T
G's and then the method that was
developed I guess in the past 10 or 15
10 years or so is a methyl code by
sulphide pyrosequencing this is where
you get a PCR product and using the pyro
mark and the system si basically assess
the percent methylation at TGS fish's
TGS at hundreds of millions of PCR
products and so this is the idea behind
power sequencing so you have a PCR
product that you want to assay at the
CGS for methylation and then you have a
power sequencing primer and then with
incorporation of either TG or CG you
know basically you have para phosphates
that are released from the incorporation
of the nucleotide and so that's so
that's where the main pyrosequencing
comes from and what that pyrophosphate
does is it drives you I'm sorry an
enzyme called fulfill a stripy formation
of ATP and the ATP is being used by the
luciferase enzyme to generate light
output basically it's a luminol metric
sa that you're detecting and it's the
gold standard for candidate gene
assessment of DNA methylation and it's
highly quantitative compared to counting
colonies and I mentioned these two
different methods because it turns out
that the genome-wide sequencing platform
is a kind of a comprehensive way of you
know colony sequencing and so then you
know I prefer to then validate some of
the genome-wide hits with pyro
sequencing as an independent method of
validation so there is also the
detection of histone modifications you
could actually cross link and sonicate
of histones
so what you get is uh basically the kids
on Optimus with the associated DNA
wrapped around them and then you use
that specific antibodies that recognize
specific modifications of histones to
pull down pieces of chromatin and then
you reverse the process link and then
you PCR amplify across your region of
interest and now that's the candidate
gene approach and now you know with
microarrays and especially with
next-generation sequencing you could
actually look at all areas across the
genome that were associated with that
particular histone modification and you
can also do this with antibodies against
specific transcription factors there
were cost linked to your odd DNA and
then do what's called a chip seek
chromatin immunoprecipitation followed
by sequencing so this is a you know the
next two slides show you some papers
that were published looking implementing
some genome-wide methylation platform so
this is the account platform developed
by dr. Andrew Feinberg here at the
epigenetic Center and I've was involved
in building the lat genome version and
then I've also been involved with
looking at hydroxymethyl silencing the
context of drug addiction and so this
was using a technique called me dip or H
needed antibody against hydroxy
methylated cytosines and then showing
basically the associate pulldown DNA on
the sequencing machine so there are
candidate gene approaches that you could
do and there are genome-wide methods to
detect different epigenetic
modifications and let me just add that
as I mentioned too much about micro
rna's but this is very similar to you
know obviously our NH seek that you
could get these RNA species and then
make libraries out of them and then put
them on the either live you know
microarray platform or in this more
commonly used a next-generation
sequencer to detect very different types
of RNA such as long non-coding RNAs and
micro rna's now let me switch gears to
what I've been working on for the past
couple years and why my work some of the
things that I did in the past couple of
years really created a need for me to
move into you know some of the
techniques and approaches in
neuroscience so I've been involved in
looking at epigenetics of stress hormone
exposure or Google corticoids and stress
and its impact on the brain and what I
was able to find in the past couple
years was that glucocorticoids can
actually directly alter DNA methylation
and as obviously this is work being done
by other fantastic labs you know in you
know around the world and it turns out
that these methylation changes persist
and that's one of the reasons that
really got me into looking at stress
hormones in the context of psychiatric
disorders so let me briefly talk to you
about the stress response the stress
response is mediated by the HPA axis
consisting of the hypothalamus the
pituitary and the adrenal glands with
endocrine output from each one of these
organs that are necessary to mount the
stress response your fight-or-flight
response and of course the end result is
the relief of stress hormone cortisol
from the adrenal gland and you know I
guess arguably I would say that the
acute stress is actually quite good for
you because it mobilizes your energy and
makes you alert your heart rate goes up
your blood pressure goes up and you know
like when you exercise in the short term
I think it's quite good for you but you
know unfortunately a lot of us are you
know living at this day and age are
exposed to a lot of chronic stress you
know sitting in from the computer like
how I would like what I'm doing now
and you know working away on grants and
things like that you know it creates a
lot of stress you know day after day and
you know week after week and so forth
and unfortunately you know that exposure
to chronic stress leads to a host of
diseases such as heart cardiovascular
disease hypertension obesity diabetes
and of course of particular interest to
me are psychiatric diseases such as
depression anxiety disorders and in the
case where you know the stressor is very
high magnitude and I guess acute you
could also be afflicted with PTSD so
there's part of bit of literature of
linking stress and stress hormone
exposure to psychiatric diseases and as
I mentioned it's a risk factor for
anxiety and mood disorders as well as
neurological diseases such as
Alzheimer's disease it turns out that
you know stress plays a pretty big role
in this particular disease as well and
one of the reasons that really got me
excited about looking at stress and
Google corticoids in psychiatric
diseases is that unlike I mean there's a
lot of things I don't know about bipolar
disorder and depression but at least if
stress plays a big role in these
diseases you know what's attractive
about stress hormones is that you could
actually measure it in the blood and as
I mentioned there are plenty of
literature linking glucocorticoids and
psychiatry to go into greater detail it
turns out that hyper core is illumined
Google corticoid resistance is often
comorbid with depression and I also
found out a couple years ago in reading
through one of these little books in on
depression that it turns out that Goethe
corticoids you know we're human stress
hormone cortisone one of the few
molecules that can actually trigger
mania and depression bipolar disorder
and I
also had the opportunity to work on
Cushing's disease so this is where you
have a tumor in the pituitary or the
adrenal gland and it basically results
in the excess release of cortisol so
they have hydrocortisone Linea it turns
out that about 60 to 80 90 percent of
these patients develop depression and
what's also interesting is that when
when these are when hyper cordially Mia
is resolved
through you know surgery removal of
these offending tumors a lot of the
cases the depressive symptoms are
alleviated so there's a kind of a nice
called effect relationship between Gugu
corticoids and psychiatric disorders
this is a very large epidemiological
study looking at you know hundreds of
thousands of people that are treated
with glucocorticoids for non psychiatric
symptoms such as asthma and lupus
rheumatoid arthritis and things like
that and it turns out that people that
were exposed had much higher incidence
of depression mania panic disorder and
suicidal behavior so I'm just kind of
hammering in this you know notion that
stress hormone actually plays a huge
role in psychiatric disorders and this
allowed me to kind of think a little bit
about the role of genes that regulate
the HPA axis or the stress response and
to see whether they're actually involved
in psychiatric disorders and it turns
out that many of these chains that are
either target genes of glucocorticoid
signaling or can actually regulate
Google corticoid signaling in the HPA
axis who are actually involved with a
psychiatric disorder so these are
numerous studies that have linked these
genes to psychiatric disorders and this
allowed me to formulate kind of an idea
as to how epigenetics actually plays a
role in mediating exposure to stress as
just for
owns two psychiatric diseases so you
have you know everybody has their
homeostatic according to dynamics you
know that obey circadian rhythm and you
know exposure to stressors and so on so
you have this kind of normal level of
homeostatic level of plasma cortisol and
then what happens when you're exposed to
prolonged or prolonged exposure to
quotas or stress is that it starts to
alter DNA methylation and other
epigenetic modifications of these HP
active genes and they start Wednesday
altered epigenetic that you're altering
their function and when that happens
they start modifying the interest the
homeostatic cortisol dynamics and how
that's important is that the
modification and changes in gene
function of HPA access genes actually
cause alterations of some of the target
genes in the brain such as BDNF this is
the brain derived neurotrophic factor
and th which I'll talk about in a little
bit which is the tyrosine hydroxylase
which regulates dopamine synthesis so
you have prolonged exposure to stress
affecting epigenetic modifications of
HPA axis genes that where some of these
HPA access genes are actually very
important in neuronal function and so
then the model that i have is that these
ultimately lead to persistent changes of
these genes of course and then to
psychiatric disorders let me just
mention briefly how cortisol works
it's a hydrophobic molecule based on
cholesterol and so it enters the nucleus
of in the plasma membrane quite readily
it binds to the glucocorticoid receptor
groovey cortical receptor dissociates
enters the nucleus and it acts as a DNA
binding transcription factor and so then
you have target genes of
cortical signaling as I mentioned to you
before the typhoon hydroxylase and the
BDNF genes that are either silenced or
overturned on and I will focus on one
particular target gene of Google
corticoids signaling called fkbp5 if you
are just kind of passed through rather
quickly but the fkbp5 gene is actually a
very important gene in regulating Google
cortical signaling and it turns out it's
also a target gene so I got really
interested in SKT p5
because some of the snips are genetic
variations in this gene were associated
with depression and from our group with
showing that it was associated with
bipolar disorder and other people have
shown that genetic variants in this gene
were associated with PTSD and alcoholism
and so forth so it seems like the SK 55
was a very interesting gene in the
context of glucocorticoid signaling but
also in psychiatric disorders mention to
you shows you this slide before
let me just add here that fkbp5 not only
regulates the intracellular Google
cortical signaling but it actually is a
target gene and so what that does is
that SK BP v gene once it becomes
transcribed from recording or signaling
goes to the cytoplasm and acts as a
ultra-fast negative feedback protein to
limit additional glucocorticoid
signaling so as you can imagine with
excess cortisol levels and excess
transcription of the fkbp5 gene you
could get this negative feedback loop
where additional Google corticoids
signaling is prevented so I wanted to
see given these findings whether chronic
exposure to stress hormone and Google
corticoids
leads to epigenetic changes in that k55
so I think this really a kind of simple
very simple experiment of providing a
group of corticoids or hooli classroom
so the rodent version is a quarry
Kathryn I'm sorry the rodent Google
coracoid is for the classroom so we gave
them in a drinking water for four weeks
and then after four weeks we tested them
you know for anxiety-like behavior on
the elevated plus maze and you know and
the tail suspension test and so forth
and then from after the test we
collected you know and examined you know
their brain regions for any changes in
you know transcription and epigenetic
changes and then we had the other half
of the cohort to see and then we let
them go for another edition of four
weeks in the absence of any additional
cortical cortical sterile to see whether
any of these changes if they were there
would persist in the absence of Google
cortical signaling so this was a kind of
a initial candidate gene study that we
did and it took a very long time for me
to actually find where DNA methylation
was changing in the blood and what you
see here in Figure B is a particular CPG
an intron one so the y axis is percent
DNA methylation using determined using
pyro sequencing and then the x axis are
the number of weeks so at four weeks we
treated them with Google corticoids Cori
classroom and then and then in the
second half of the four weeks we let
them recover and you can see here in
figures B and C that - there were at
least two CPGs that underwent epigenetic
changes and they lasted for about a week
in the blood and then they kind of
returned back to baseline by the time
the animals were sacrificed at the
eight-week period and then when you look
at the expression of this at kv-85 gene
you can see that after four weeks you
know it becomes elevated and then during
the recovery period
it comes down to baseline so this was in
the blood and then we show in the brain
that there's another region so this it's
a very kind of to specific epigenetic
changes occurring with Google cortical
treatment you can see here at the top
panel which is the hippocampus in the
bottom is the hypothalamus and you can
see in panel Figure B that there's a
kind of four CPGs or methylation changes
that occur with Google cortical
treatment in another intronic region and
what's interesting about this study was
that in the eight-week period when
they've gone without glucocorticoids for
four weeks you can see that the
methylation changes persist now I I'm
showing you these figures to emphasize
the fact that the effect size or the
percent methylation difference is quite
small and this was when I was just
starting out learning about you know
guru coracoid and you know doing these
DNA methylation assays and this this
kind of got me to think you know is this
a neuron specific or a a non neuron
specific event and you know but what
kind of circuit trees are involved and
so forth and that kind of got me started
with looking at specific neuronal
populations in other experiments and of
course to show that demonstrate that
cellular heterogeneity plays a part what
I use here in this particular experiment
is a cell line it's a very simple Mouse
simple campus cell line and of course
there's no cellular heterogeneity there
because these are neurons that were
transformed and so it's fairly
homogeneous in tissue culture and what I
was able to show is that sure enough
when you actually look at one population
of cells methylation differences are so
much bigger when you're not looking at
both tissues and then so figure a shows
the expression changes with Google
cortical treatments of the
five gene and then figures the figure B
shows basically that one intronic region
in the mouse brain where we solve
methylation change and sure enough
there's a fairly big methylation change
that also persists in the recovery
period now we treat these animals for
I'm sorry these cells for about seven
days instead of you know four weeks and
we're able to observe a fairly robust
epigenetic change and of course did some
experiments just to show what is so what
why is the glucocorticoid methylation
change important and these two figures
kind of show you why they are so you
know I got these cells again that were
previously treated with Google
corticoids and then when you treat them
again with a group and analog Google
particular dexamethasone you can see
here on the top figure that when it's
been previously be methylated by a
previous exposure to glucocorticoids
effects the next time you treat the
cells with Google corticoids the
response is higher so methylation is
playing a role in Vienna a more robust
expression of this activity five gene
and then to make sure that the intronic
region has a has functional relevance
what I did was then cloned that a piece
of DNA into a CPG lattice vector so this
is a commercially available vector or
plasmid that although cpgs have been
changed to I guess T G's so that the
plasmid itself does not get methylated
and then you're calling that your
fragment of interest and then you
compare when that fragment has been
enriched from methylated or when it's
unmethylated so that the piece of DNA is
driving the expression of a luciferase
gene in a methylation sensitive
and you can see here in the left panel
the on the left side is the fkbp5
intronic regions that you can see a
fairly robust expression when the
methylation is not added to the CPGs
compared to the one all the way to the
left where it's been heavily methylated
by an enzyme called SSS one methylase
and then on the right panel you can see
that a consensus group of cortical
response element that binds to the
Google cortical receptor also show
similar methylation sensitive activity
so at least from these figures it seems
like as far as that KB p5 is concerned
that it has this methylation sensitive
I'm sorry that it that it responds
epigenetically to chronic glucocorticoid
treatment so then I started asking the
question you know what other genes are
out there that change epigenetically
with chronic exposure to stress or
glucocorticoids and then of course you
know if you have if you do find multiple
targets are there any common pathways
that we could think about so this is one
of the I guess the beautiful things
about doing genome-wide investigation
because you're not only looking at one
gene now you're kind of generalizing
your finding to the genome and you're
able to now identify you know trends or
pathways or gene sets that might be
important in disease so let me tell you
briefly about the sure select platform
this the one that I use is it's a sure
select platform by Agilent basically
you're hearing DNA and attaching
adapters your ligating adapters to your
here DNA and then you're using the
the Agilent technology where they've
developed specific RNA baits against
specific genomic loci and you're pulling
these sequences out of solution and then
after enrichment using streptavidin
coded magnetic beads so these RNA deeds
the RNA species are biotin o'lady and
then you use streptavidin coated beads
to pull them down out of solution with a
magnet and then you might supply treat
the DNA and then you put it on the
sequencing machine so it actually sounds
quite simple the experiment itself is
quite simple but the analysis is
actually quite challenging so then let
me just tell you briefly about what this
platform entails this is the Mouse
methylome target platform and it targets
the CPG Islands teacher specific DMR's
or differentially methylated regions and
it takes into consideration or targets
multiple regulatory features such as CPG
Shores and shelves dnase hypersensitive
sites that we know have been shown to be
associated with you know binding all
transcription factors histone
modifications and so on but it's got a
lot of these regions across the genome
and I prefer for now using such
platforms rather than you know whole
genome sequencing because for lots of
reasons it's still quite expensive and
you know these are very gene focused
platform and then what we do after a
sequencing is a whole slew of
bioinformatics tools that we implement
so this was done by our bioinformatics
group led by dr. Peters Andy and I as
size wouldn't and you know there's you
know kept you know we align the
sequences perform quality control and
then you know there's a whole slew of
statistics that get generated in terms
of you know what the what the target
percentage
and the redeath and coverage and so
forth and then there are methylation
calls so basically with the align
sequences at a particular CPG you're
determining how many reads represent
that particular CPG and then using those
reads a percent methylation is
determined and this is the figure that I
showed you before just to emphasize the
fact that when you do a genome-wide
sequencing it's a fancy way of doing
colony sequencing so you're looking at
you know basically when you do
genome-wide sequencing each read
represents kind of a bacterial colony
that you would have done if you had done
colony sequencing and you use this
method to basically in a
semi-quantitative way calculate or
assess percent methylation so this is a
experiment that I did with the Google
corticoids treated animals so I use one
cohort to look at the fkbp5 gene and
then once I had some findings regarding
epi you know with epigenetic changes at
the fkbp5 locus I then looked at a
genome-wide using the methyl seat kit
and so these are some of the statistics
that we that are provided by the you
know the bioinformatics analysis so you
get the total pair then read how many of
them are mapping the mapping efficiency
and then we look at you know how many
number of cpgs are being covered and
then how many of them are on target
meaning that how many of them how many
of them are actually targeted by the
methyl seed platform and then from there
you know we calculate an average of for
each CPG or on on average you know
what's the read depth for each of the
CPGs that are being targeted and in this
case we've got about anywhere from 24 to
31 X coverage which is a fairly decent
you probably don't want to go
below like 10x coverage for these types
of assays and so we for this particular
experiment we pulled our DNA samples
with I guess two animals representing
one sample and then this is the kind of
the output that you get at the end we
use a we use a analytical algorithm
called a be smooth or BSC and basically
four sets of there's a window of CPGs
that are changing in methylation so then
what is what the algorithm does is kind
of smooth over those areas and then we
look for regions where from the
smoothing between the cases and controls
are treated or untreated or vehicle
treated animals there's a statistically
significant difference so what the
algorithm does is it provides a list of
genes of course the genomic coordinates
and their associated genes and all the
statistics
for those regions and it ranks them
based on I guess a arbitrary statistical
parameter and it also provides a very
nice PDF plot of your samples and what
the methylation patterns are in this one
at the bottom is a a PDF plot that shows
the regions a particular DMR
differentially methylated region between
vehicle and Kotick are untreated samples
of blood samples in these mice and then
what you do then is you know for the
hippocampus at the top and for the blood
at the bottom you then you know design
specific candidate assays and I've
mentioned to you the bicycle pyro
sequencing platform in the previous
slides you go in and try to validate a
specific regions and you can see here
that for both the hippocampus
the blood you can see a nice independent
validation by xo5 pyrosequencing and
then what you can do with genome-wide
approach is to look at specific pathways
and I performed the tech pathway
analysis in both blood and hippocampus
and what's really interesting is that
you know there's lots of these very
disease relevant pathways that pop up
from the analysis that are relevant to
you know diabetes and obesity and
psychiatric disorders I mentioned I
showed you in the previous slide in that
nice figure with the effects of chronic
stress that these are actually these
pathways are actually relevant to some
of these diseases that are associated
with chronic stress exposure and then
you can also do additional some
interesting analysis such as you know
where are these dmrs where are these
differently methylated regions and what
we found is that a lot of them are in
the intronic regions so this is very
consistent with other studies of stress
and group coracoid signaling where they
show that the google chronically
response elements where the group of
cortical receptor binds to DNA is
actually in intronic region so this is
very consistent with those studies and
then when you look at the regions in the
context of CPG Islands
you know we originally thought that CPG
Islands were these regulatory regions
and so forth but a lot of these regions
as far as Google cortical signaling is
concerned fall outside of CPG Islands
which I thought was interesting but of
course this is something that's been
published for quite some time in cancer
as well and then one of the things that
I thought was kind of interesting was
that it turns out that a group of
corticoids and the in the genes that are
epigenetically modified by them
remarkably between you know in blood and
the hippocampus there's a very similar
image of lots of DNA methylation events
so what we know from the action of
Google coracoid is that they they could
up regulate or down regulate genes and
in this case as far as epigenetics is
concerned that most of these are events
are lots of methylation events so I'm
not sure how that reconciles with genes
that are silenced by methylation and of
course finally we you know having
provided you with the background in
epigenetics and some of the some of my
research now we going to some of the
epigenetic approaches that I've adopted
and implemented in neuroscience so this
is kind of working progress and some of
the things that I've been thinking about
and some of them are implemented and
other ones I would like to do and so let
me just say that you know the one of the
primary functions of neurons of course
involves action potential propagation
you know with ion channels and receptors
and of course neurotransmitters and so
you know why you know study epigenetics
I think that epigenetics could be very
complimentary to neuroscience because it
allows us to examine learn long term
gene dysregulation in the brain so you
have you know neuronal differentiation
neural development you know especially
sexual maturation of neurons you know
during adolescence and so on and then
there's exposure to toxic ins such as
led BPA alcohol and then other
environmental factors such as stress you
know famine and of course we know that
like genetics plays a role in
psychiatric and neurological disorders
which I think you know I hope that you
know neuroscience will shed tremendous
amount of light on and I think that all
of these are all of these fields will
you know all of these topics will
require a bit of epigenetic approach to
further augment neuroscience platforms
and techniques so the kind of the main
obstacles that I encounter when I start
thinking little bit more about you know
epigenetics and the brain is that
there's a tremendous amount of tissue
and cellular heterogeneity in the brain
and of course it's the most complex
organ in the human body and you know
when I say help cellular heterogeneity
you know tension you know I meant you
know nuance versus you know the glia the
microglia and and so forth but also
within the populations of neurons
there's even in a same brain region that
is the hypothalamus you know there are
specific neurons that perform very
diverse functions and so presumably have
different epigenetic signatures on so
that is something that I had to think
about a little bit and then of course
you know when you want to do you know
really nice epigenetic experiments you
want to enrich for these you know these
neuronal populations or even from
neurons specific ones with specific
function but then at the end if you you
know do the sorting techniques and so
forth how much do you have at the end so
the limiting tissue amount is a huge
problem for me so let me just tell you
as I mentioned before about foursomes
activated cells only I think it has
become an indispensable tool for me in
terms of isolating specific neuronal
types for epigenetic experiments so
basically this involves in one set of
experiments labeling your nuclei that
you've you know isolated in this case
from human post-mortem tissues with a
neuron specific antibody just in this
case moyenne or fox 3 and then what you
do then is you know the prepared nuclei
from neuronal and non-neuronal cells
feed it through the cell sorter and then
the you know there's a excitation
wavelength and then there's the emission
of fluorescent molecules that are
attached to the antibody against these
specific neuron specific proteins and
then the machine is able to sort
physically a sort
antibody positive versus antibody
negative or Thank You valley-
populations of cells and then what I did
then is to look at a particular glial
specific gene it is a very conserved
region in the promoter of GSA P or glial
civil area acidic protein and it's
highly expressed in non-neuronal cells
and so you see that there's a huge
methylation difference between the no n
plus vs. annoying and - populations of
cells you can also do this obviously
with blood that I think this is what has
was the the original intent of the
factoring machine right because they use
it for immuno phenotyping or you know
for immunology so what I did in this
case is to label P cells B cells and
neutrophils with their specific C D
receptor binding antibodies and then
sort and then to show that actually the
methylation changes in the blood do not
occur in as much in details or
neutrophils but actually they occur in G
cells so this is a better that you know
lots of now epigenetics is employed in
neuroscience and so when I started to
look at my animal model using this
approach so on the last figure you can
see that there's a once again in the
mouse cortex in this case fairly
significant methylation difference
between the new on positive versus non
neuronal cell populations at the GS ap
promoter and then the middle panel shows
I kind of the bulk cortex tissue that
you know that I use for methylation
analysis and you can see that there are
methylation differences but it's very
tiny
and it's only significant in one CPG and
then what I did then is to fax sort
these tissues as I get in panel a and
then when you look at the same at KB p5
region in the no n+ Google coracoid vs.
vehicle treated animals that there's a
much bigger effect size with
statistically significant differences so
this kind of demonstrates that
the importance of you know cellular
modernization meaning that year for
doing epigenetic research in
neuroscience and this is just the
beginning that you need to kind of
enrich for a either the neuronal
fractions or a very specific population
themselves this is a work by a colleague
and a collaborator of mine and this is
actually probably one of the best
methods that I've seen better or better
methods to isolate specific population
of cells so this was work done by dr.
minyak in our department and this was
published in science in 2013 and what
she did in this experiment was basically
use a fluorescent retrograde bead or
beads with different colors excitation
or emission on wavelength and injected
these retrograde beads into the frontal
cortex versus the nucleus accumbens
that's indicated by a green versus red
and what you see here is that what
happens here is that over time about 3
weeks
the the beads retrograde to the ventral
tegmental area which is the hub for
dopaminergic neuron so you're basically
labeling dopaminergic neurons based on
their different projection sites to the
nucleus accumbens or the frontal cortex
and during that time what they do is
that they've stressed these animals and
these animals of course it gets further
complicated into a genetic disease you
know was psychiatric disease model
versus B wild-type and what they notice
is that in these animals
transgenic animals that have the human
trans gene for a gene called despond
disrupt in schizophrenia one when
they're stressed their dopamine levels
go way down so then what they did was
then oops what they did was then you
know isolate the ventral tegmental area
after the stress regimen and then trips
and ice itself and then they
facts were that based on the different
wavelength from the green versus the red
and what they show is that using
extracting DNA from these frontal cortex
specific dopaminergic neurons the
promoter actually is hyper methylated in
these transgenic animals that are
stressed so the e is for environment or
once they are stressed and GXE is the
gene environment interaction group where
the animals the transgenic animals were
exposed to stress and then when they do
so in this case they're looking at
colony sequencing each row represents
you know the number of cpgs that were
assayed in this case it's 11 and then
the black represents methylated black
box represents methylated white box
represents unmethylated and you can see
here that there's fairly dense
methylation patterns in these transgenic
animals that were stressed so there's an
interaction between the the gene the
transgene itself and exposure to the
stress so this is a really cool
experiment and then I you know in a
subsequent publication collaborated with
her to show that force to replicate this
colony sequencing experiment using
pyrosequencing at the targeting hydroxyl
exchange the panels are not bit
different but you could still see the
methylation changes that occur and then
also show in other genes such as BDNF
and at KD p5 that there are other genes
that are changing epigenetically so this
was a another even better method to even
go deeper into specific types of neurons
that you know I mean so these are
neurons of the ventral tegmental area
that are dopaminergic but yet based on
their different projection sites you
know doctor neo was able to isolate
these two populations and do epigenetic
analysis and and to finally to add that
there was no there were no methylation
changes in the ones that the neurons our
project
to the nucleus accumbens and then of
course there are other methods that you
could use in this case you could use
genetic models so you could have labeled
dopaminergic neurons in other ways using
crossing you know animals that carry
they pre recombinase enzyme driven by a
dopaminergic promote neuron promoter and
then you cost them with flux tomato gene
caring mice to label dopaminergic
neurons and then you could combine that
with like a retrograde bead to
specifically now label dopaminergic
neurons only so there's genetic models
that you could implement and then of
course you know at the end of these at
the end of these procedures where you're
enriching for specific neuronal subtypes
or even nuanced to do your epigenetic
essays while you do when you have so
little amount of DNA so then this is a
challenge that I had to think about and
I actually use a small animal study to
demonstrate that you can actually get
decent sequencing libraries from very
small amounts of starting material so I
use a animal model of prader-willi
syndrome I know it's kind of a bit of a
gear change shift here but it's a animal
model that carries a sword 116 deletion
- this is a particular slope RNA cluster
and and as I mentioned to you about
genomic imprinting this is a genomically
imprinted loci where the pattern of
deletion leads to a hyperphagia so they
you know the animals are humans eat a
lot it's uncontrolled eating and then
they develop obesity and so we use this
animal model and we looked at the type
of sour hypothalamic rqi so this is a
region of the hypothalamus that controls
you know feeding and satiety and so
forth and what I did was to use a used
needle biopsy so this is a very small
area of the hypothalamus and I could all
me you know get a tiny little punch
using a blunted needle to get probably a
few milligrams of tissue and from this
amount of tissue you know I was able to
generate both RNA and DNA and so before
I jump into you know epigenetics of this
particular brain region I wanted to see
what it was there even is there even a
rationale to look at epigenetics in the
first place
so using the RNA extracted from these
samples I performed RNA seek and then
found that you know there's a whole slew
of these genes that are implicated you
know they're differentially expressed
between control and you know the
prader-willi syndrome model that
necessitated that justified looking at
epigenetics to see how what is mechanic
mechanistically driving these expression
changes so this is a work that's ongoing
right now but we've successfully
sequenced basically libraries made from
about 80 50 50 to about 150 nano grams
of starting material so this is similar
to the amount of DNA that you would get
from sacks sorted experiments for the
the animal work that was done by dr.
niwa you know it ranged anywhere from
about 200 - you know like 50 nano grams
of DNA after you factor a particular
dopaminergic neuron species of neurons
and so instead of using the traditional
methyl seek platform of the protocol
which you know requires 3.5 micrograms
of DNA for making libraries we use a to
stick DNA methylation kit by Illumina
and then combine that with the mouse
methyl C I adamant
so this basically platform uses target
enrichment first and then bisulfite
conversion before you do the adapter
ligation so in this particular step you
tend to lose a lot
DNA and so you could actually afford to
start with much less material so this is
a starting material that we had so it's
about you know ranges from about 150
nano grams to about 50 nano grams of DNA
and you can see here from this tiny
little hump this is DNA that's been
sheared at about hundred seventy-six
base pair average that we didn't have
much to start with but then when you go
through this particular procedure to the
end you could actually get a fair a
fairly decent amount of sequence of all
library so this is you notice that the
size is bigger to indicate that the
adapters have been successfully ligated
and this is a high sensitivity screen
tape on the cake station which is the
next generation bioanalyzer to basically
show you the size and the quantity of
your library and then you know still
little bit skeptical about how with
these libraries are I don't want to
spend thousands of dollars at the
sequencing core to sequence these
samples if you know there's nothing in
the middle so then I performed a my seek
experiment so this will cost you about a
thousand dollars at the core to perform
it then this is not to you know do
percent methylation analysis but just to
see whether there is a lie noble
sequences from your library and so so
far the libraries look pretty good
considering that we started from very
small amount of material so then it
remains to be seen you know you know
after this result I will be you know
putting the samples on the high seat
with a much larger platform to do the
methylation analysis and then hopefully
find dmrs specific to the animal model
and then validate by pyrosequencing
so these are the kind of the epigenetic
approaches that I at showing you that
need to be kind of modified specifically
for tackling the challenges in
in neuroscience and now I'd like to
acknowledge the people in the psychiatry
department including dr. neva and others
and endocrinology my longtime
collaborator Gary wand and of course the
people at wonderful people at Agilent
Karolina Jonathan and Josh who have been
tremendously helpful in implementing the
methyl sig platform thank you thank you
for that informative presentation dr.
Lee it's time for Q&A if you have any
questions we'd like to ask dr. Reed
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appear on the screen
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as the time for
available if we are unable to answer
your questions dr. Lee will follow up
via email following the presentation so
our first question is why do you have to
validate genome-wide sequencing results
by another method
yeah thank you for this question
uh it's it's I would love to just be
able to do these genome-wide essays and
then you know do the pathway analysis
and so forth and call it a day but we've
had lots of experiences where we've done
the genome-wide assays but then you know
they don't validate so this was
especially a problem with some of the
Irate based platforms that we had used
and if you're looking at you know you're
looking at different issues or you know
cancer versus normal I mean it's these
are big differences that you could
actually robustly you know validate
using power of sequencing but then when
you when you're working with
glucocorticoids and especially in
tissues that perform similar functions
you know like dopaminergic neurons and
things like that methylation methylation
differences might not be all that big in
which case some of the platforms might
not be as good for detecting them I mean
they will give you a mess you know genes
and reasons for you you know saying that
this might be important but unless you
validate them it's really hard to know
whether that's a real finding or you
know or something that the algorithm an
analytical algorithm that just kind of
spits out at the end of the analysis
thank you
so much another audience member has
another question is it possible to do
chip a save such as chip feet on
neuronal isolate yeah that's a very good
question
so I'll you know the you know I stopped
mainly to DNA methylation because I
think it's you know fairly convenient
you know it has been convenient for me
because the you know when you deal with
post-mortem DNA post-mortem tissues you
know I think for a lot of the samples
the mRNA is toast so you know I'm not
sure what kind of results you get from
mRNA RNA seek and then you look at
histone modifications and you know also
once again the some of the proteins
might be might have been degraded as
well and so you know DNA is one of these
very stable or DNA methylation is one of
these very stable modifications that you
could actually detect in tissues such as
you know from post-mortem studies and
another thing is you don't need as much
starting material and so you know I've
done some chip assays and you know the
reproducibility I mean so they don't get
me wrong you could definitely do chip
seek on you know a small number of cells
or small sample tissue samples but I
think from at least from my experience
you know the reproducibility is a lot
lower than you know when I work with DNA
so because of that reason and of course
you know with the all the whole million
gazillion modifications that sound on
histones I you know kind of shy away
from chromatin on a chip cheek or chip
assays yep thank you
there are wonderful questions coming in
but we only have time for just one more
doctor the an audience number ones like
to ask why do you use target enrichment
wouldn't it be better to do whole genome
sequencing yes so this is this is often
asked I guess especially you know like
you know NIH grant reviews and things
like that you know I hope obviously you
know it doesn't get any better you don't
get more comprehensiveness then you know
then doing a whole genome bisulfite
sequencing because you know you're
getting you know the entire you know
three billion base pairs of DNA from
that but you know it turns out that you
know I mean what do you what do you do
when you get all that information it's
an analytical nightmare I think and also
because there's also repetitive
sequences that make up you know more
than 50% of the genome and so I you know
and this is also demonstrated or you
know emphasized by people who studied
whole genome approaches and it turns out
that you know like good 80% of you know
CPG methylation you know from whole
genome assays do not provide much useful
information
you know genes but you know I think make
up about you know 1.5 to 2 percent I
think of the genome and so you know
finding robust methylation differences
in in gene deserts I'm not sure what you
could do with them at this point unless
you could link them to some sort of a
you know long non-coding RNA or
something like that so I like I like
using the target enrichment because it's
very gene-centric and it you know
targets also regulatory regions that may
change in methylation and has functional
relevance so i'd like to focus on those
and of course there's the economics the
financial aspect of it if you're going
to do or sequence the whole genome
whole genome bisulfite sequencing you
know you're going to have to sequence
basically also laying of high seek so
that's about you know twenty three to
twenty five hundred dollars of one main
for the entire genome of one sample and
that's going to provide you at best
about 10x coverage whereas if I'm doing
the targeted enrichment as you've seen
you could you know multiplex in the
example that I shows you I loaded four
samples per Lane and then they give me
about 25 to 30 X coverage which I think
is a lot better than the 10x coverage
all over the place that you would get so
there's definitely an economic cost here
savings that you would get from doing
target enrichment as well thank you once
again dr. Lee for a wonderful
presentation and thank you Agilent
Technologies from making today's
educational webinar possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing for up to june
sixteenth to seven 2017 you will receive
an email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who have missed
today's wonderful live event that's all
for now thank you for joining us we hope
you come back again goodbye